every state is like its own country and
that's kind of Because of You Britain
when we were starting this country all
the settlers here that were in the 13
colonies were all like a little bit
shell-shocked by the monarchy happening
over in Britain and so they're like if
we're gonna make a country we can't make
it too powerful we can't make the
government too powerful
so instead we're going to distribute the
power among all the states and let them
have their own constitutions let them
experiment with different policies the
federal government will still be
powerful in some things but the states
will have rights this was like a big
debate and it made its way into the DNA
of our country so today Texas is very
different than New Hampshire is very
different than Oregon is very different
than Alabama
kind of cool